plos Gustavson you're a member of Nobel
Committee for chemistry can you tell us
some words about this year's price so
the price this year is about the
cellular systems that preserve the
Unitec information so it turns out that
the DNA molecule which includes the
anything information ourselves that
depth molecule is frequently damaged and
it might also be mutated and that can be
caused by both by external agents like
sunlight the UV radiation in sunlight by
smoking different agents in smoking but
it can also be a internal sources like
reactions with water which happens at
the quite high frequency actually we
also get mutations in the DNA when we
replicated DNA so every time a cell is
divided we need to create two new copies
of the DNA and together these different
sort of sources or mutations and damage
can create a real problem for for our
genomes and preservation of genetic
material and what these free price low
rates this year have done is that they
have investigated and described in
chemical detail important processes
repair pathways that can correct these
mistakes when they arise and it's both
in there are three different areas so
DNA repair that we've been focusing on
one is this base excision repair take
care of all mutations or chemical
damages I should say two bases many of
them spontaneous or add realistic we
also have the mismatch / system which
takes care of the rare mistakes that DNA
polymerase leaves behind when it
replicates the DNA and then we have the
nucleotide excision repair system which
takes care of for example you've induced
damage and
and other types of for example agencies
smoking so that's what this year's price
is about was they said discover they
made that the history power system so
the existence of some sort of dinner
repair is something that goes back a
very long time and probably the first
first identification repair system was
discovery of an activity called food to
liars in bacteria which could overcome
you've induced damages but at that time
the mechanisms for how that happened was
not known at all this was back in the
40s and then in the early in the middle
of the 50s when when they saw with the
extracts actually transforming that
those phenomenons in in pseudo cells and
in extracts it's something that all
these free stock lorries have done they
have taken so the preliminary
observations and made it into sort of
real chemistry and when it comes to the
food Elias which I didn't talk about
during this price price present a press
conference it's actually a sis on yahoo
has both cloned the gene identify the
protein and described a mechanism for
this really important enzyme the reason
I didn't talk about this repair today
was that this is actually something
that's found only in bacteria we don't
have this type of repair in ourselves
but all these are the three tabs are
repair they were first identified in
simple cells and then it turned out that
this knowledge was applicable also to
our higher human cells and that we have
very similar systems that take care of
damage to 2 r.d and I
but the repair system is not enough we
still have diseases costs but by the
damage of DNA how big part of the
diseases is you as it's their origin in
this process so one can say that Dean
imitations how to put this I mean if you
think about cancer i would say that all
forms of cancers start with a mutation
or a DNA damage that's how they start we
know so I mean that's how important is
this and if you don't have repair system
that take care of the damages este as
they occur the frequency of cancer for
example becomes much much higher and
there are diseases where you have the
way you have disturbed repair mechanisms
they don't work as they should they are
in them they are themselves mutated and
that then you get very high levels of
cancer one example is said they're
mapping onto sure this is characterized
very carefully by by an excellent
American scientist his name is Jung
clever and he found all these different
genes that cause the Dharma pigmentosum
and then it turns out that all these
genes actually were all most of them
actually encode components of the
nucleotide excision repair system in
human cells and these the people or the
patients suffering from this disease
they cannot repair you've induced damage
as they should and they get extremely
sensitive to to sunlight they need to
stay stay inside and when will they go
inside when they are subjected to UV
light they develop different types of
tumors and they often die from mullen
melanoma or or this type of skin tumors
so that that's that's the importance of
it but then of course a certain level
imitations is also something that's
probably needed so even if the cells try
to lower the levels as much as possible
of course you don't want a frozen genome
because the Orion evolution requires
that or at least some mutations that
take place and that we can utilize for
selection a little flexible yes even if
I think that the focus in luring in in
luring mutation rates doctor I mean they
can't have positive effects are there
any concrete drugs or treatment
treatments that have developed from this
research I can say that we understand
now how some treatments work so for
instance radiation is something that
it's you know widely used in the
treatment different types of cancers and
what one thing one importantly to
radiation does is that it induces breaks
in DNA so it breaks down the DNA in
cancer cells and breaking down the DNA
means that we overwhelm the repair
system the repairs is there are so many
DNA damages that it cannot cook and then
the cells might choose to be into
programmed cell death or apoptosis and
so suddenly we understand at least one
way that that is that radiation works
there are also new drugs being developed
where one tries to to utilize the effect
the fact that many cancer cells have a
defect repair system order to begin with
so by by inhibiting repair actually in
the cancer cells you might get something
that we call synthetic lethality and
that will sort of specifically kill the
cancer cells this is a very interesting
concept has been
currently developed and I think that
there are a number of different
pharmaceutical industries that are
looking into this and I think there are
one or two drugs that are actually
already available that builds on this
concept so this is a field that's very
active it's very active and if you think
about DNA damage I mean think about all
the things that we read about cigarette
smoke we read about avoiding sort of
sunlight or think about catastrophes
like that in Fukushima with the nuclear
so with radiation if the threat is to
our DNA it's our genomes that are being
prepped and these are the machineries
that trying to fix it for us actually I
thought that Alfred Nobel was a chemist
chemistry was his peel what do you think
he would say about this year's prize I
think it would be happy and proud I am
very happy I think that this is a prize
in the tradition from the discovery of
the DNA understanding how did the DNA
sort of read by transcription and now
understanding how you actually preserve
this genetic information which is so
important for life thank you very much
thank you very much